>> Sean: AS WE CONTINUE, FAMED
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALAN
DERSHOWITZ HAS LONG CALLED FOR
MUELLER'S WITCH HUNT TO COME TO
AN END.
HE IS COMPARING THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION TO THE
TACTICS OF THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION.
JOINING US NOT TO EXPLAIN,
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK "TRUMPED
UP," YOU KNOW, I NOTICE YOU GET
ATTACKED BUT DO YOU BEEN VERY
CONSISTENT ON THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ON THE CRIMINALIZATION
OF POLITICAL DIFFERENCES.
>> OH, YEAH.
TODAY WE SEE THAT MUELLER
ANNOUNCES THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
HE WILL GO AFTER TRUMPED FOR ANN
ROSENSTEIN SAYS HE CAN DO IT IS
COLLUSION.
NOW HE'S CONFRONTING INVENTING A
CRIME.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS
COLLUSION.
YOU CAN'T MAKE JUST MAKE HIB
CRIMES.
NOBODY LIKES COLLUSION.
IF COLLUSION HAD OCCURRED, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A POLITICAL SIN.
BUT NEITHER ROSENSTEIN NOR
MUELLER CAN MAGICALLY MAKE UP A
CRIME AND SAY COLLUSION IS A
CRIME.
YOU WANT TO MAKE COLLUSION A
CRIME?
PASS A STATUTE.
IT'S NOT ON THE BOOKS.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT THE
VIOLATION OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
ALL THAT GREGG JARRETT WAS
TALKING ABOUT?
I THINK IT'S INTERESTING, ONE
WEEK AFTER PAUL MANAFORT'S HOME
IS RATED AT HIS POOR WIFE IS
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAS
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAA
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAN
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAC
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAS
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAA
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAY
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WA,
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAT
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAP
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAC
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAL
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAA
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAD
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAE
THROWN INTO HANDCUFFS, WHICH WAW
WEISSMANN TACTICS, BUT TO A WEEK
AFTER, ROSENSTEIN AUTHORIZES
MUELLER TO DO IT.
>> SOMETHING VERY WRONG WITH
THAT.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL SHOULD HAVE
VERY NARROW JURISDICTION.
IT SHOULD BE SET OUT IN ADVANCE
SO EVERYONE CAN SEE IT AND NO
EDGE.
CONSTITUTION JOKES ABOUT EXPO
FRACTAL LAWS.
THE POLICIES ARE ABOUT FAIR
WARNING AND CONSTRAINING THE
GOVERNMENT.
THE GOVERNMENT, WHEN YOU HAVE A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR, SHOULD KNOW
AND EVERYBODY SHOULD KNOW, WHAT
HE'S ENTITLED TO AND WHAT IS NOT
ENTITLED TO LOOK AT.
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR IS GOING
TO LOOK AT EVERYTHING.
HE'S BEGINNING TO LOOK AT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PERSONAL
FINANCIAL MATTERS BEFORE HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
WILL HE START LOOKING AT THE
WOMEN WHO WERE ALLEGING ACTIONS
AGAINST HIM?
WHERE DOES IT STOP?
WE KNOW THE CLINTON SPECIAL
COUNSEL STARTED WITH WHITEWATER
AND ENDED UP WITH THE BLUE
DRESS.
THAT'S WRONG.
>> Sean: JONATHAN TURLEY, A
SMART LAW PROFESSOR, ALSO ON THE
OTHER SIDE POLITICALLY THAT NOR
I AM, HE MADE A GOOD POINT.
HE THOUGHT THE APPOINTMENT BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
PROSECUTOR, JOHN HUBER, THAT
HELPS TRUMP BECAUSE IT MOVES
FASTER.
>> I AGREE WITH THAT.
THAT'S WHAT SHOULD'VE HAPPENED
TWIN SPECIAL COUNSEL WAS
APPOINTED.
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE APPOINTED A
SPECIAL COUNSEL IN THE
BEGINNING.
THEY SHOULD'VE HAD SOMEONE WITH
ADMIT JUST AS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, LOOK AT IT
INITIALLY, LOOK AT THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF RUSSIAN INVOLVEMENT IN
THE ELECTION AND THEN, AS IT
LOOKED LIKE THERE WAS EVIDENCE
OF CRIMES THAT COULDN'T BE
INVESTIGATED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, THEN --
>> Sean: YOU THINK THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS A RIGHT?
WE DOING IT THIS WAY?
>> I THINK THIS TYPE HE HAS A
RIGHT.
THE OTHER PROBLEM IS ROSENSTEIN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE REMAINS ON
THIS CASE.
HE IS THE MAJOR WITNESS AT ANY
DECENT TRUMP LAWYER CALLS.
HE'S THE GUY WHO WROTE THE MEMO.
THE FIRST QUESTION YOU WANT TO
ASK HIM IF THERE IS AN
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
INVESTIGATION IS, HOW CAN THERE
BE OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE?
YOU WROTE THE MEMO AUTHORIZING
THE FIRING.
>> Sean: HE RENEWED FOR FISA
APPLICATION AND HE APPOINTED
MUELLER.
HE'S CONFLICTED A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT WAYS.
HERE'S WHAT WE DISAGREE.
I ARGUE THAT HILLARY CLINTON
VIOLATED 18 USC 793.
SHE DIDN'T WANT CONGRESSIONAL
OVERSIGHT.
MISHANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
SHE SUBPOENAED -- HER EVIL ALSO
DELETE THAT, 33,000, ACID
WASHING THE HARD DRIVE, AND
BEATING UP YOUR DEVICES.
>> AS A RESULT OF THAT, SHE LOST
THE ELECTION.
BECAUSE COMEY INVESTIGATED AND
SAID THERE WAS NO CRIME BUT WHAT
SHE DID WAS CARELESS.
DON'T YOU THINK THAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO DEAL WITH
THAT?
>> Sean: I LOVE YOU BUT IS IT
CARELESS WHEN YOU ACID WASH YOUR
HARD DRIVE, DELETE SUBPOENAED
EMAILS, AND BEAT THE CRAP BU OUT
EMAILS, AND BEAT THE CRAP BU OUO
EMAILS, AND BEAT THE CRAP BU OUF
YOUR BLACKBERRIES?
>> SHE DIDN'T DO IT.
WAS SHE APPROPRIATELY
INVESTIGATED?
>> Sean: LISA PAGE AND PETER
STRZOK AND JAMES COMEY AND
ANDREW McCABE AND LORETTA
LYNCH MEETING BILL ON THE
TARMAC.
>> I DON'T LIKE ANY OF THAT.
I THINK BILL CLINTON MADE A
TERRIBLE MISTAKE HAVING THAT
MEETING BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT LED
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL RECUSING
HERSELF LEADING TO COMEY TAKING
OVER THE INVESTIGATION, LEADING
TO THE STATEMENT HE MADE,
LEADING TO HER LOSING THE
ELECTION.
>> Sean: STRZOK AND COMEY
WRITING THE INVESTIGATION --
>> IT'S WORTH LOOKING INTO.
>> Sean: IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
FIXES END.
>> AGAIN, MAY BE A POLITICAL SIN
BUT NOT A FEDERAL CRIME.
>> Sean: OKAY.
IF YOU WRITE AN EXONERATION
BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION --
>> NOT A CRIME.
I DON'T THINK THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN OBSTRUCT